[Music]
summer 1945 and the war is 1 million men
old
[Music]
hang on kid keep your eyes shut tight
and drink
[Music]
they're moving you back now don't give
up just how on the road back is bumpy
and maybe the pain blurs your eyes but
listener the sound of battle grows dim
and now one question cuts clearly
through the haze which man will you be
the one who gets hurt and dies or the
one who gets hurt and lives when the
dizziness stops when the fog clears
an Army nurse will be at your side a
woman who has meant safety and comfort
and home to thousands of men before you
a woman who will mean all those things
to you a nurse brought another
American's blood to your side to pour
new strength into your veins a nurse
handed clamps to the surgeon and counted
sponges
a nurse prepared and administered the
anesthetic and Watts to constantly for
any telltale change in your breathing or
blood pressure all of them working with
the same purpose to ease the pain of war
to help save lives
[Music]
the preparation for the moment that
would bring the army nurse to your side
began months ago back home in the United
States it started with four weeks of
basic training in those days perhaps the
nurse wondered why she had to sit
through seemingly endless classes and
submit to rigid discipline often while
muscles ached and groaned she may have
wondered why it was necessary to take
those long hikes or grope her way
through a ghast area yet there were
demands that would require of her
perfect physical health and stamina the
strength to stand up under the rigors of
combat nursing now when the four weeks
of basic training are finished the army
nurse is ready to serve no matter where
her assignment may take her she might
find herself stationed in a General
Hospital right here at home
or perhaps you'll find herself assigned
to a mobile hospital unit overseas after
she arrives she may have to help build
the very hospital in which she is to
work for the field hospital or the
evacuation hospital like a circus must
be able to pack up and move on at a
moment's notice its primary function is
to offer immediate surgical treatment to
the wounded and that means following
ever-changing battle lines everyone
pitches in when a mobile hospital goes
up enlisted men doctors and nurses just
one small instance where basic training
pays off those muscles toughened and
hardened during the four weeks of basic
back home are equal to the job in the
field the army nurse lives roughly and
works gently
there's no glamour and her life is far
from spectacular she sleeps under
hastily pitched canvas on a GI cot under
GI blankets she trains her mind to act
as an alarm clock because time is
important a wasted moment may mean a
wasted life
she lives a life completely stripped of
luxuries and yet she has asked for no
more luxury than a patient's smile when
the pain is eased she eats regular GI
rations the same as the rest of the army
does and often at irregular times the
hours are long and the demands
never-ending and as a result the nurse
has learned to make use of every moment
of her off-duty time
[Music]
a GI helmet may not be exactly what
she'd choose to wear to her kids
sister's wedding
but it makes up for its lack of style by
its versatility
it's a beauty parlor laundry basin and
anything else you might wish to call it
a little community in size 7 she may
spend some of her time writing letters
not the having a wonderful time wish you
were here kind but letters filled with
all the drama of her days with stories
of the courage and spirit of the men
over whom she watches she made to vote a
few moments to prayer
[Music]
others too lounging about talking of
home she may long to wear the evening
dress sent from home but probably only
gets the chance to talk about it usually
she wears olive drab or a battle gray
and is battle ready throughout the day
on duty or off her uniform at all times
is her badge of service but however she
spends her time she always wants to
return to the hospital where the wounded
are fighting for their lives for first
and foremost and at all times she is a
nurse offering professional and skilled
care to the sick and wounded a nurse
first a woman second and an officer
third might well serve as the slogan for
every member of the nurses Corps
complete recovery of the patient depends
not only upon the use of drugs but on
the skill with which they are
administered and the care that follows
the nurse must be capable of recognizing
at once any symptoms in her patients
which demand immediate treatment because
of serious consequences are to be
avoided medical treatment must be on
hand the moment any symptoms appear
professionally skilled and capable in
her there is the tenderness of all women
of mother and sister and friend her
touch and voice lend encouragement
instill hope it's the surgeon who saves
a man's life it's the nurse whose loving
care helps him to live
[Music]
crisis has passed
the patients begin to sleep again now
the pain is just a bad memory the field
hospital is a stopover to give them
immediate surgical treatment as soon as
possible after their wounded
[Music]
the evacuation hospital is also just a
stopover on the trip back through the
medical chain here facilities for
treatment are more complete than those
of the field hospital and here too
the nurse plays an increasingly
important part in the vital period of
treatment and convalescence after three
or four days the patients are well
enough for the trip back to the general
hospital
[Music]
trains will be waiting for them hospital
wards on wheels
[Music]
each train carries in addition to
medical officers and enlisted
technicians for surgical nurses and to
medical nurses all of whom are on duty
from 7 a.m. to 9 p.m. and as far into
the night as they are needed
when speed means life evacuation may
take place by plane because of these
flying hospitals men are alive today who
otherwise would have died in the jungles
of Burma or on the beaches of Normandy
these patients are thoroughly checked
before the takeoff they will be watched
over and checked again when the plane
lands
[Music]
while in the air the flight nurse is in
complete charge she is ready to handle
every emergency and does everything a
doctor would have to do except operator
error evacuation is difficult it
requires specialized skill and training
and the flight nurse must be prepared
for the unexpected for the next moment
it may happen at the general hospital in
the theatres of operation other skilled
teams of surgeons and nurses stand ready
to take over where the frontline
hospitals left off whether a hospital is
under canvas out in the field or in a
solid structure in a city it's routine
like the nurses routine doesn't vary and
its principal aim remains fixed to offer
the best possible medical care to the
sick and wounded nurses sterilize the
operating equipment the surgical gowns
and gloves
[Music]
prepare drugs lay out the instruments
the doctor will need for his next
operation and keep accurate records of
each patient's history and progress
while in a civilian hospital the ratio
is one nurse to every three beds in an
Army Hospital it's a great many times
that number to help lift the burden from
the nurses shoulders enlisted
technicians trained in special schools
will be assigned to work under her
direct supervision one of her biggest
jobs is to teach these technicians both
in the classroom and in the hospital
wards this means added responsibility
for the nurse for although she will have
less personal contact with her patients
she must direct the activities of the
personnel assigned to her so that the
treatment and well-being of her patients
is assured relaxation and entertainment
are an important part of medical
treatment to this General Hospital
overseas comes an all-star show and the
Army nurse shares the fun with her
patients the sound of laughter from home
often means more than medicine later on
she may spend a few minutes with the
star and there may be times when she
herself is the star of the show like
this nurse the first woman to land on
Bougainville the umpire calls batter up
and the game is on army vs. army as the
nurses play the wax
[Music]
this infield may never play in the Polo
Grounds
but maybe one of their patients will off
duty for a while some nurses may choose
to stroll through the streets and
buildings of an ancient city others may
prefer a round of golf or a swim
somewhere if the weather's right but
it's always back to duty back to the
sick and wounded back to the hospital
around which the life of the Army nurse
revolves those patients scheduled for a
trip back home for the final period of
convalescence travel on a hospital ship
as fully equipped as a stationary
hospital now as before the army nurse
stands by ready to minister to every
need
[Music]
next up a demarcation hospital
[Music]
then a General Hospital in the United
States and complete recovery and this is
the end of the long chain of evacuation
the General Hospital back hold here the
Army nurse works patiently with her
hands her head and her heart here she
gently guides men back to the way of
life they fought to protect although she
may have volunteered to serve overseas
although she may chafe at what she
considers the inactivity of working in a
hospital in the United States or Alaska
or Panama the Army nurse soon learns
that a battle line is wherever a soldier
is stationed but words of praise can
measure up to these women whose very
lives are given to nursing a wounded man
a million wounded men back to life and
health and yet praise is offered long
hours of tireless service are remembered
and recognized the army nurse decorated
for bravery and valor above and beyond
the call of duty
and these nurses imprisoned for three
long years by the Japanese ask only that
they be returned to duty for they will
never forget the faces of the American
men tortured and killed by the enemy
wherever transports are taking our
soldiers they are also taking the army
nurse to work by day by night on distant
battlefields to help make shattered
bodies whole to bring sales to faces
twisted with pain to serve at the side
of a man hurt by war directly by
shellfire or indirectly by disease this
is the army nurse USA ready to serve any
under any circumstances in time of need
[Music]